[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on Cheryl how can we
help hi thanks for taking my call my
husband just retired the end of June and
we're still trying to get our retirement
budget together but my kids keep
thinking we've got all this money that
we can spend on them and I feel so broke
constant L even though we're not really
giving them money they've got trust
funds that my parents set up for them
when my parents passed away and I just
don't know what to do anymore so Cheryl
these trust fund kids are hounding you
for money yes and you're but you're not
giving it to them I no but you feel bad
because you're not giving it to
them yes well I thought you said you
feel broke and I'm confused how you
would feel broke broke because of them I
think you feel broke because of you
all no okay we have we have more money
than what we're telling the kids we have
then how can you feel
broke because I'm constantly being told
we need money for this we need money for
this we need money for this so I mean
it's getting to be Christmas my daughter
wants Christmas money she how old your
us to sign for a loan for my
17-year-old granddaughter to get a
2,20 car because my daughter's credit is
down the tube and do you want to know
whose problem that
is not my daughter's problem yeah it's
not your problem Cheryl these I'm just
this is your family and you love them
but I am in an impartial person out here
and I'm telling you these folks are
entitled you have done the right thing
you have said no I'm not going to fund
this and that and I'm certainly not
going to do it at your whim if you feel
the need to be generous you can choose
when and how you'd like to be generous
for your family but they do not get to
treat you like Grandma ATM and come to
you whenever they feel like they need
this or that you are exactly right and
if I were in your shoes I would not feel
bad about that for a hot second uh
Cheryl what's the stat wish well okay
we'll come back to that what's the
status of the trust funds are they do
they already have access to them or are
they waiting to get access to them I
have I'm the only one that has access to
him right now my son inherited uh my
parents house as part of his trust we
ended up having to take a loan against
that trust because they would not upkeep
the house and the city has an ordinance
where you can't have just weeds all over
your front
yard so son we ended up having to take a
loan against the trust to pay someone to
come out and Landscape their front
yard the car for the granddaughter is a
loan against my my daughter's trust why
are they lo I wasn't about to cosign
because I don't want to make car
payments right okay but my question is
does the trust say is is the trust
delineating when and when certain
amounts are supposed to be distributed
to them and they're just not getting
what they felt like they were supposed
to or is it something different the
trust gives my
daughter uh $1,500 a month and that's it
and she gets that and she gets that
every month and she wants above and
beyond that is that what you're telling
me and she wants above and beyond all
right so let me let me my son has a
house to live in right now his rent is
$275 a month to help pay for the sewer
the insurance the property taxes that
type of thing all right Cheryl here's
the problem um your kids know about the
trust and they have known about the
trust for a while enough to let their
behavior be so immature and so lazy that
they can't even cut their own grass and
you've got to take a loan first of all
you didn't have to do any of this you've
done it I think you called today because
you're at your wits end and should be
and you should be but I will
say um you have a lot of responsibility
here and I'm not saying this to be mean
to you at all I'm saying that now is the
day for you to say enough is enough and
you got to decide what you going to do
here on this trust um I don't think
they've earned it and uh but I I don't
want to get into the minutia of this MH
but uh because I don't think that that
distracts from from what you need to do
what you need to do is say this is what
you
get and and if it were me I'd change the
the trust to where they don't get any of
it till they show themselves worthy and
responsible of it but uh at this point
they get what they get from the trust
and you need to say that's it that's it
and there's no more asking Mama for
anything which means you are going to
say no to all these loans against the
this is this is this is over and this is
a family meeting wow a come to Jesus
meeting where you make it really really
clear how things are going to be going
forward because these kids are
manipulating you emotionally you sound
like an emotionally weary lady who
actually needs to take charge and let
the kids gripe and complain it's time
for them to be adults I know that's not
fun to hear but this isn't going to
change until you cut them off and be
okay with cutting them off create your
free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life